con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de una preocupación que
tenemos y me incluyo muchos en este año
2023 y es Hacia dónde va a ir nuestra
economía un 2022 bastante golpeado por
todo lo que tiene que ver con el
acontecer Internacional la guerra que
vino a grabar todos los problemas
económicos de muchísimos países en el
mundo esta sombra de la recesión que se
puede avecinar para este año 2023
también una clase media que sigue siendo
golpeada por la inflación en casi todos
los países del mundo y un freno al
crecimiento mundial nosotros Entonces
vamos a saludar a Erick que Bear
Villegas él es profesor de economía del
tec de Monterrey y decano de ciencias
económicas de la universidad
internacional de Berlín también por
supuesto como no nos acompaña desde
davos nuestra enviada especial al Foro
económico mundial nuestra periodista
económica Daniela
Daniela Ya le voy a dar paso para que
también se incluya esta conversación que
vamos a tener con Erick pero Erick
quiero empezar con usted preguntándole
Hacia dónde Entonces vamos en materia
económica este 2023 definitivamente si
nos vamos a enfrentar a esta recesión
que dicen muchos expertos
bueno Muy buenos días a todos es
obviamente imposible predecir yo soy
algo optimista para algunas variables
que nosotros no vamos a terminar en una
recesión Así de grave como la del 2008
sin embargo hay algunas señales de los
mercados que sí nos dicen que hay
preocupación por parte de los bancos que
están aumentando las provisiones es
decir esperas más impagos la clase media
también se está viendo afectada en
algunos países como España por hipotecas
variables que ahora están prácticamente
destruyendo lo ahorrado y Cuanto más
impago haya más preocupación va a haber
también por ese flujo de liquidez
entonces Si eso continúa Yo creo que el
tema de la recesión es anticipable pero
si finalmente los diferentes actores
económicos logran de una u otra manera
evitar esa situación entonces creo y ahí
sí me veo un poco más optimista ahora el
problema también tiene que ver porque en
Estados Unidos hay una profunda división
entre lo que se espera que la sed va a
ser con las tasas de interés y con lo
que la sed realmente podría ser
aumentando más las tasas que encarecería
el dinero y que también llevaría
inclusive a países emergentes los
contras Colombia etcétera A ver una
depreciación de sus monedas mucho más
fuerte y eso obviamente implica un
empobrecimiento general Esto está atado
a la inflación Esa es la principal
preocupación actual de los países
emergente perder el poder adquisitivo y
a su vez la competitividad que tienen
frente a digamos socios comercial
un placer saludarlo desde acá para
preguntarle Pues precisamente este foro
es el escenario para discutir ese tema
pero primero en plata blanca qué
significa una recesión para las personas
de a pie y segundo que pueden hacer
desde acá para evitar esa recesión
de la pregunta no la escuché bien por
temas de señal pero si nos preguntamos
Qué se puede hacer para evitar realmente
por un lado digamos el el lo que hace la
familia digamos el ciudadano de a pie es
tratar de reducir los gastos
innecesarios al máximo es decir tratar
de ahorrar y de dejar ese colchón
financiero disponible lo mejor que se
pueda para tener algo para los
imprevistos es decir no tratar de
invertir ahorita en algo innecesario No
dejarse llevar por narrativas económicas
de meter dinero en algo que uno no
entiende que esto tiende a pasar mucho
cuando la preocupación
digamos deviene también en un tipo de
esperanza en cosas que no entendemos y
por el lado de los gobiernos claramente
ser responsables es algo que no se está
viendo en Latinoamérica se hacen
anuncios muy graves anuncios que dejan
ver las rupturas institucionales que
existen que dejan confundidos a los
inversionistas y a la vez eso digamos
que se enmarca en ese panorama la
incertidumbre en donde hay una guerra y
todo lo que nosotros conocemos Entonces
es un llamado a la prudencia recordemos
que la economía el tema de las
narrativas de lo que decimos de los
chismes de este tipo de cosas que
empiezan a esparcirse por los mercados
tienen unos efectos muy profundos
entonces Cuanto más prudencia se pueda
cultivar mejor va a ser y ya en el plano
después de las familias realmente es
tratar de evitar al máximo los gastos
innecesarios pero obviamente cada quien
Define que es necesario y que no lo es
no cosa que es muy difícil decir desde
arriba desde una posición digamos de
torre de Marfil claro Erick Pero lo que
sí también es cierto es lo que va a
pasar digamos en materia de empleo y
también la calidad de los mismos porque
se espera que este año haya digamos la
mitad de los empleos que hubo el año
2022 y también en la calidad que no sea
la igual que vimos el año pasado por
ejemplo Entonces qué va a pasar también
en este sentido y Qué consecuencias va a
tener esto población
Bueno si sigue aumentando el problema
del desahogo y el consumo termina siendo
financiado por más deuda efectivamente
eso puede llevar a que en el sector real
las empresas cierren Si eso pasa No
Solamente vamos a ver menos empleo Y de
lo que estás diciendo es empleos de peor
calidad eso es sumamente grave digamos
del punto de vista socioeconómico Ahora
yo no creo mucho en esa predicción de
tener la mitad de los empleos estaríamos
hablando de una situación como la que se
vive en los años setentas de esta
inflación se hablaba en Estados Unidos
ante el choque económico del petróleo de
tener desempleo muy alto inflación Muy
alta y crecimiento económico
prácticamente nulo yo espero y fue muy
optimista que no habrá una estanflación
y también Creo que este tema de los
empleos no va a ser tan estructural y
realmente digamos destruya una gran
parte de lo que se ha logrado ganar en
los últimos las últimas décadas sin
embargo eso va a depender de las
políticas públicas y de la seriedad
sobre todo en países que son sumamente
vulnerables como los son los países
latinoamericanos y también del desenlace
que se ve ahorita con el conflicto con
la la invasión rusa de Ucrania pero para
latinoamérica es clave es clave que los
son gobiernos sean sumamente
responsables y prudentes y no hagan
anuncios al final hacen que las
capitales se vayan para otros países
Erick uno de los temas principales esta
semana ya más de mediano y largo plazo
es la crisis climática
Qué se puede hacer desde este foro
precisamente para abortar esa crisis y
más cuando hay tantas críticas de la
gente que dice que inclusive Este no es
un buen ejemplo de lucha contra la
crisis climática porque los presidentes
de las compañías y los ministros los
primeros ministros y los jefes de
gobierno llegan hasta aquí en jets
privados que son 50 veces más
contaminantes que los trenes
yo ahí soy sumamente escéptico sobre el
tema de de davos porque realmente parece
más es un club de conversación lo que es
importante es los temas sobre los cuales
se habla claramente en ese club de
conversación es importante ver qué temas
están tocando qué expectativas existen
Pero por otro lado pensar que ahí se va
a derivar una solución Clara yo ahí Soy
bastante escéptico por lo que estás
diciendo que es sumamente simbólicos que
estén llegando en este tipo de de jets y
al final obviamente es algo que
difícilmente se va a poder evitar creo
que es un tema muy simbólico pero que
nos dice a nosotros que ahí no está la
solución al tema del cambio climático
necesariamente sino las políticas
públicas y también en la efectividad de
lo que hacen las empresas dentro de
ellas mismas a través por ejemplo de la
reutilización de materiales en las
empresas textiles Y así sucesivamente yo
ahí sí lo digo abiertamente soy
sumamente séptico de lo que se derive
del foro económico mundial creo que es
un club más de conversación y de
narrativas pero que hay que estar muy
pendientes de los temas que toca